preuve par 3 accueille Pierre Laurent le
secrétaire national du Parti communiste
français et sénateur de Paris bonsoir et
merci d'être avec nous votre opposition
à la ligne Holland Vals se renforce
chaque jour et surtout à l'heure du
débat sur le budget rectificatif pour
financer le PACT de responsabilité mais
vous nous direz tout à l'heure si vous
approuvez au moins la volonté du chef de
l'État de réorienter l'Europe ce que
vous demandez depuis des mois maintenant
avec moi Pierre glachan de l'Agence
France Presse notre partenaire comme
chaque semaine avec Daily Motion et bien
sûr perine tarnaau de Public Sénat
d'abord pierrelaurent ce que certains
appellent le retour du volontarisme
économique ou politique avec notamment
le dossier Alstom et Arnaud mondtebourg
un volontarisme qui pousse aujourd'hui
donc l'état à devenir actionnaire
Alstom PSA ecomove peut-être demain
est-ce que en partageant le pouvoir bien
sûr avec les actionnaires est-ce que
vous partager cette vision est-ce que
vous la prouvez pour le moment c'est un
volontarisme très timide quand même
parce que on a plutôt ce qui domine
plutôt c'est le laisser aller le fait
que la politique économique soit semble
être
dictée par par le meddef au plan
national et par les pressions des des
des groupes financiers autour de nous
dans l'affaire Alstom il a fallu que le
gouvernement se rende à l'évidence il
s'agit d'un secteur
stratégique et le risque était réel
d'une perte totale de souveraineté sur
une filière stratégique donc le le
l'État a mis un pied dans la porte mais
il a en même temps en faisant alliance
avec général électrique oui mais il a en
même temps donné un peu les clés de la
maison à général électrique qui va
dominer le groupe et il y a deux
questions qui se posent maintenant
est-ce que l'État va jouer un rôle actif
va lui-même définir des objectifs de
politique industrielle va essayer pas
seulement de subir la situation et
d'accompagner la stratégie de général
électrique mais va jouer un rôle
réellement actif dans le groupe ça on ne
le sait pas alors qu'il est parce que le
gouvernement n'a défin aucune aucun
objectif de politique industrielle
claire il y a un deuxième aspect du
dossier qui mérite d'être éclairé c'est
l'accord avec bouig parce que quand même
on découvre bah on découvre quand même
que à l'origine de ce bascul
d'actionniat il il y a la décision de BG
d'essayer de faire une bonne affaire en
revendant à bon prix ses action qui lui
avait été cédé par l'État je le rappelle
pour justement jouer un rôle de de
maintien du groupe industrielle or là
maintenant il semble que BG fasse un peu
les marchands de tapis pour essayer de
faire une bonne opération financière ve
pas perdre l'argent ça c'est sûr et
c'est c'est légitime ou ça serait ça
serait la moindre des choses qu'il n'en
gagne pas parce que il a empoché B
depuis qu'il est rentré dans le capital
plus d'un milliard d'euros de dividendes
tiré de sa participation dans le groupe
Alstom sans jouer véritablement un rôle
avec sans définir véritablement
d'ambition industrielle maintenant il
veut faire d'autres opérations
financière donc il vend ses actions et
il essaie de les vendre au plus cher à
l'État j'espère que l'État va résister à
cette pression vous nous dites en
quelque sorte que B c'est déjà payé un
petit peu sur Alstom c'est largement
payé et il essae d' d'en remettre une
couche en sortant du groupe en essayant
de de faire une une bonne opération
financière donc il faudra y regarder de
près et être vigilant sur les conditions
réel de l'accord avec B qu'on ne connaît
pas à C mais vous estimez que par
exemple mettre 2 milliards d'euros comme
on l'évoque hein de la part de l'État ce
serait trop cher payé de toute façon non
mais c'est ça n'est pas la question
quand on est on a affaire à un groupe de
cette importance je pense que que l'État
mettre de l'argent sur la table me
paraît me paraît normal il faut il faut
bien que
mais mais on parle le cours de l'action
je crois est à 28 € BCK voudrait en
tirer 35 € on voit pas très bien
pourquoi il aurait cette prime à la
sortie
alorsession oui d'accord mais c'est lui
qui a décidé de sortir du groupe il a
pris cette décision alors qu'il était
chargé d'être soi-disant l'actionnaire
de référence assurant la stabilité du
groupe on va regarder donc effectivement
ces deux points pierre Laurand mais
d'ors et déjà AR Mbour se félicite car
il dit que donc les emplois comme les
centres de décision vont continuer à se
développer en France est-ce qu'il a bien
agi oui mais là on verra on verra si ça
si ça se fait vraiment parce que on est
il y a des il y a des paroles qui sont
prononcées il y a des engagements qui
sont pris je dis il faudra être vigilant
sur ces questions moi je ne la parole
donnée par expérience dans la dernière
période ne me suffit pas donc vigilance
et je crois qu'il faudra accompagner les
salariés et les syndicats dans cette
vigilance alors il y a une conjonction
des mécontentements de toute nature en
ce moment après la SNCF c'est la SNCM il
y a les contrôleurs aériens il y a les
intermittents du spectacle est-ce que ce
sont des mécontents ou des jusquau
boudhistes non ce sont ce ce sont des
mécontents sûrement pas des jusque
boutiistes ce sont des mécontents et
surtout des gens qui mettent sur la
table des propositions parce qu'on
oublie de dire que dans tous les cas que
vous venez de citer à chaque fois ce
sont des des gens qui en AR à user de de
la grève parce qu'ils ne sont pas
entendus sur des propositions qui
rendraient pérenne leur situation ou la
situation de leur entreprise dans le cas
de la SNCM par exemple dans le cas il y
a des engagements qui ont été pris sur
un plan de développement de l'entreprise
et ces engagements ne sont pas respectés
donc les salariés sont obligés d' d'en
venir à l'action pour faire respecter la
parole donnée dans le cas des des
cheminau on affichait des objectifs qui
étaient on va avoir une loi de
ferroviaire qui va reconstruire l'unité
de l'entreprise et puis on s'aperçoit
que l'unité souhaitée n'est pas vraiment
totalement au rendez-vous de la loi donc
non mais là la parole est revenue au
Parlement oui la parole est au est au
Parlement le débat va continuer
d'ailleurs au Sénat la loi ferroviaire
va venir le 8 juillet et nous allons
continuer pour notre part à porter des
amendements pour conforter l'unicité de
l'entreprise qui n'est pas garanti par
la la la loi qui je le répète
contrairement à ce qu'on on n'explique
pas assez ça
qui crée trois établissements publics
distincts bon c'est vrai rassemblé mais
avec un statut qui ne change pas pour
les mais qui fait mais qui fait courir
un risque progressif de partition de
l'entreprise avec la mise en concurrence
et l'entrer dans la privatisation
rencontrer hein tous les acteurs de ces
mouvements sociaux en ce moment Pierre
Laurent tout à l'heure prés sur le
terrain tout à l'heure les intermittents
vous allez voir également la CGT pour
souffler sur les braises pas du tout
j'ai rencontré les intermittents tout à
l'heure pour faire le point avec eux du
dossier parce que il y a nous sommes
dans une situation très paradoxale le
gouvernement annonce à la fois qu'il va
réouvrir la discussion une table ronde
et il commence par agréer un accord
alors que cette discussion est faite
pour changer cet accord bon la logique
aurait voulu qu'on fasse différemment
qu'on fasse la négociation et puis
ensuiteou mais la négociation a lieu
entre les syndicats on parle d'un accord
social paritaire elle va elle va avoir
lieu elle va avoir lieu elle fait
rentrer dans la discussion ce qui est
une très bonne chose les représentants
des intermittents qui en avaient été
exclus au moment de la négociation de
l'accord avec le mdeef le 22 mars
dernier et elle fait rentrer à la table
des négociations l'état donc nous nous
nous félicitons de ça mais maintenant il
va falloir porter des propositions
précises oui alors le ministre du
Travail François repsamen appelle lui
les intermittents à la raison hein il
leur demande de venir justement à la
table de négociation pour remettre à
plat tout le système est-ce que vous
vous vous vous faites la même démarche
mais ils vont venir à la table des
discussions ils demandent ça fait 10 ans
qu'ils demandent cette discussion donc
ils ne vont pas pratiquer la politique
de la chaise vide ils vont probablement
maintenir par des actions qui leur
appartiennent la pression parce que
cette discussion va durer 6 mois et donc
il faut que pendant cette discussion
vous comprenez bien qu'il ils sont quand
même ils sont quand même vigilants parce
qu'on on on leur promet une discussion
qui va durer 6 mois mais on commence par
agréer un accord qui dit le contraire de
qui dit le contraire donc ils sont quand
même interrogatifs sur la sincérité de
cette discussion donc ils vont maintenir
la pression et nous allons les y aider
parce que je le répète les problèmes que
posent les
intermittents il là aussi ils avancent
des propositions qui rendrait le
systèmeme le problème qu'il pose c'est
le milliard d'euros de déficit non mais
vous savez très bien que ce chiffre que
ce chif ce chiffre est faux et ça a été
démontré dans les discussions y compris
les discussions au Sénat tout le monde
le reconna il n a absolument pas 1
milliard de
déficit les intermittents ont fait la
démonstration ils sont 3,4% des
allocataires et il touchent 3,4 % des
indemnités donc ils ne sont pas
producteurs de défic tout le monde n'a
pas les mêmes chiffres hein là vous en
cite mais ça c'est des chiffres il
suffit de regarder les chiffres
officiels et de les vérifier ce de la
Cour des comptes évidment ne sont pas
ceuxl hein ah non mais la Cour des
comptes monsieur mig c'est devenu le
grand prêtre de l'austérité là lui c'est
c'est le degré zéro de la politique
économique didig oui le degré zéro de la
la pensée économique c'est-à-dire on va
tout ratiboiser on va tout réduire la
dépense publique est par
définition une catastrophe pour le pays
les salaires de la fonction publique il
faut les réduire et les conséquences de
ça sur le
pays ça ne semble pas l'intéresser et
quand Valérie rabau la
rapporteur
s'inquète de la det des déficit oui mais
quand Valérie Rabo la rapporteur du
budget à l'Assemblée nationale sort une
note de Bercy qui dit mais si on met en
œuvre cette politique violente
d'austérité ça va produire non pas une
réduction mais une augmentation du
chômage tout le monde dit oh là là ces
chiffres sont suspects alors explique
qu'on m'explique par quel miracle les
chiffres de Didie Migot sont absolument
sacrés il ne faudrait pas les discuter
tandis que ceux cités par Valérie n'ont
aucune validité en vérité vous savez les
chiffres moi j'ai j'ai une maîtrise de
science économique donc j'ai j'ai j'ai
travaillé sur ces question là on peut le
faire dire Paris ce qu'on veut voilà
donc c'est ça fait partie du débat
politique et il faut de l'expertise
contradictoire donc le côté Didier Migot
a parlé tout le monde doit se ranger à
la pensée de Didier Migot bah ça fait
pas partie de ma culture donc il y a un
débat à avoir sur les les stratégies
économiques et
et sur Didier mig et sur Didier MIG à
votre place il y avait Jean-Claude
Mailli de FO la semaine dernière et il a
dit que Didier Migot c'était la nouvelle
margarette Sacher oui mais c'est c'est
c'est c'est vrai c'est vrai c'est c'est
le
c'est le dernier rapport publié par la
Cour des comptes il faut le lire de près
est un vrai semblable c'est c'est
vraiment le il faudrait tout je le
répète il faudrait tout sacrifier dans
la dépense publique et tout irait mieux
mais qui peut penser une chose pareille
dans un pays où investissement public un
pays comme le nôtre où l'investissement
public a toujours joué un rôle
structurant pour développer pour
développer le pays par exemple qu'on
nous explique comment on va faire la
transition écologique et la transition
énergétique sans mettre de l'argent sur
la table pour l'investisement ce que
propose François Holland dans le cadre
européen on va en parler dans un instant
mais j'ai quand même encore une question
sur une taxe qui ne s'appelle plus
l'écotaxe mais le fameux péage qui va
prendre la place pour les poids lourds
avec donc une version un petit peu enfin
considérablement réduite avec et un
manque à gagner évidemment pour le
financement des infrastructures comment
on fait pour compenser l'idée était
éventuellement de taxer les sociétés de
d'autoroute il par que c'est impossible
mais je ne vois pas pourquoi c'est
impossible et il y a même mieux à faire
puisque on pourrait renationaliser les
société d'autoroute et nous avons
d'ailleurs il y a quelques jours dans
notre niche parlementaire provoqué un
débat sur cette question et tout le
monde nous a dit c'est une très bonne
idée parce que la privatisation est une
erreur et aujourd'hui il y a une ronte
autorité autoroutière qui alimente les
caisses d'actionnaires privés et tout le
monde nous dit on ne peut pas le faire
parce que ça coûterait de l'argent à
l'état de renationaliser les sociétés
d'autoroutes et bien nous nous disons
qu'au contraire ce serait un
investissement de le faire puisqueon
aurait un retour sur cette
investissement puisque la rente
autoroutière au au lieu de continuer à
aller dans les mains des actionnaires
privés et bien reviendrait dans le giron
de l'État et pourrait justement servir à
financer des infrastructures nouvelles
pour les trans voilà que l'État
réinvestisse en quelque sorte les
sociétés d'autoroute oui absolument
parce que la privatisation qui a été
voulue par Nicolas Sarkozi a été un
gâchi pour le pays les l'essentiel des
infrastructures autoroutières sont
amorties et aujourd'hui c'est les
autoroutes ça rapportte c'est d'ailleurs
pour ça que ça a été privatisé et nous
nous trouvons que c'est anormal le c'est
c'est l'État qui a fait l'investissement
de départ c'est à lui aujourd'hui de
avec C C argent là de continuer à
développer le réseau c'est l'idée aussi
qu'on prête à seolen Royal là vous lui
dites et ben il faut y aller oui moi je
je je je si elle si elle va dans ce
sens-là et notamment de travailler à à
récupérer de l'argent sur les sociétés
autoroutières elle a raison de le faire
alors vous parliez des Investissements
d'Avenir hein alors peut-être dans le
cadre européen puisqu'on va maintenant
évoquer la politique européenne que
François Hollande enentend réorienté à
l'occasion de l'installation bientôt
d'une nouvelle commission à Bruxelles
avant donc les questions de pierre
glachan de l'Agence France-Presse voyons
sur quel curseur voudrait jouer le
président français qui s'est d'abord
tourné vers les chefs d'État et de
gouvernement de centre-gauche paulind
dame une offensive sur le front européen
sonné par les résultats des élections de
mai dernier François Hollande propose un
agenda pour réorienter l'Europe première
priorité la croissance déjà samedi
dernier il défendait se mettre mot au
côté des h chefs d'État socio-démocrates
réunis à Paris une gauche européenne
unie pour demander à Bruxelles
d'assouplir le PACT de stabilité les
priorités que nous avons retenu c'est
d'abord la croissance et l'emploi en
utilisant toutes les marges toutes les
souplesses de ce qu'on appelle le pacte
de stabilité et de croissance car pour
François Hollande et ses amis
socialistes plus de souplesse c'est
ralentir la marche forcée vers la
réduction des déficits budgétaires les
fameux 3 % en faisant sortir par exemple
du déficit les dépenses d'investissement
pour ce député PS la force de frappe de
cette gauche modérée crée un terrain
favorable on a la chance d'avoir encore
une fois l'Italie avec nous on a la
chance d'avoir les socio-démocrates
allemands avec nous on a la chance
d'avoir le groupe socialiste au
Parlement européen qui est sur cette
ligne politique ce qui n'était pas une
évidence et donc oui on a les éléments
le rapport de force aujourd'hui pour
foncer et pour le faire une fausse piste
et même un fantasme pour Jean biset qui
estime que François Hollande ne prend la
tête que d'une coalition de
centre-gauche faible face à l'Allemagne
avec un vice-chancelier allemand Sigmar
ri régulièrement contredit par Angela
Merkel en France c'est pas des soutiens
c'est de la défiance de son aile gauche
qui est de plus en plus
bruante en Italie mattho Renzi souffle
le chaud et et le froid mais il est
entre guillemets rattrapé par ses 2000
milliards de dett et tant que à Monsieur
Sigmar Gabriel et au SPD je vous renvoie
aux déclarations
régulière tant de la chancelière que du
ministre des Finances et dès que l'un ou
l'autre parle monsieur Sigmar Gabriel se
voilà un petit peu tous ses soutiens
jeudi et vendredi se tiendra le sommet
européen un sommet qui pourra accoucher
du nom du prochain Président de la
Commission européenne et de sa feuille
de route si Junker est élu il devra
choisir entre l'austérité de Madame
Merkel ou le pragmatisme des
socio-démocrates en faveur de la relance
voilà donc cette inititive du de l'État
français pose bien des questions pierre
glachan N a rejoint journaliste à la FP
vos questions à Pierre Laurent Monsieur
Laurent bonsoir alors cette Europe
réorientée sous impultion de François
Hollande vous y croyez écoutez la
réorientation de l'Europe elle est
absolument nécessaire moi je je plaide
pour ça depuis depuis des années
malheureusement François Hollande a raté
le coche après son élection il avait dit
qu'il renégocierait le PCT de
budgettaire il ne l'a pas fait donc on
s'est mis sous les fourches codines de
la Commission européenne et d'Angela mer
kel et aujourd'hui il nous dit je vais
réorienter l'Europe et en même temps il
nous dit je vais soutenir la la la
candidature à la présidence de
Jean-Claude Junker qui est le candidat
de la droite à la présidence du
Parlement EUR quand même il propose un
assouplissement des règles budgétaires
qui était une des demandes que vous
avanciez depuis un certain nombre de
temps et aussi un plan d'investissement
sur 5 ans pour financer des
infrastructure l'emploi des jeunes
autant de mesures qui
devraievoir pour le moment pour le
moment c'est des c'est des paroles parce
qu'à chaque fois qu'il faut passer non
mais à chaque fois qu'il faut passer à
des actes concrets moi je constate que
ces bonnes paroles ne vont pas au bout
si elles vont au bout je vais les
soutenir mais par exemple quand au
Parlement européen quand au Parlement
européen il y a quelques semaines on
discute le 4e paquet ferroviaire
c'est-à-dire une nouvelle vague de
déréglementation du transport
ferroviaire que font les députés
socialistes européens ils ont voté pour
les seuls qui ont voté contre c'est les
députés
du Front de gauche et de la Gauche
Unitaire européenne le groupe dans
lequel nous sommes au Parlement européen
donc qu'on passe aux actes moi je veux
bien entendre toutes les paroles sur la
réorientation de l'Europe je dis qu'on
passe aux actes et que le gouvernement
cesse de bavarder sur le sujet mais
qu'il qui qu'il agisse ce qui veut dire
entrer en confrontation avec public avec
les orientations d'Angela Merkel cette
fois-ci François Hollande n'est pas seul
quand même il a plusieurs chef d'État et
de gouvernement sociau-démocrate
derrière lui et il y a eu une
convergence autour de ce thème l de la
réunion de Sami dernier je je rappelle
quand même que beaucoup de gouvernements
en Europe sont des gouvernement de
coalition par exemple j'entends dire les
les sociau-démocrates Allemands sont
avec nous je rappelle qu'ils sont dans
un gouvernement de coalition avec Angela
Merkel
donc s'il y a s'il y a s'il y a une
garantie dans le Parlement européen
c'est plutôt le groupe de la gauche
unitire européenne qui vient celui dans
lequel nous sommes qui vient fortement
se renforcer qui compte maintenant 52
députés et qui va être un groupe
extrêmement utile pour mener cette
bataille nous nous à chaque fois qu'il y
aura une occasion dans le Parlement
européen d'obtenir une directive plus
sociale d'obtenir une réorientation nous
allons la saisir mais je le répète il
faut que sur ces sujets on
passe on passe au Act vous pourriez-vous
passer un petit mot d'encouragement vous
pourriez-vous passer un mot
d'encouragement Enat si c'est votre
j'ai vous continuez de le taper dessus
là non je je dis que il faut que les on
passe des bonnes intentions à des actes
concrets voilà ce que je dis si vous
voulez un mot d'encouragement c'est un
mot d'encouragement plein d'exigigences
expectative prudente oui oui c'est le
moins qu'on puisse dire oui et le les
chefs d'État et de gouvernement
également sociau-démocratees ont samedi
dernier se sont prononcés en faveur de
Monsieur Jean-Claude juner qui est
pourtant issu de la droite à droite
modérée pour la présidence de la
Commission européenne alors comment
réagissez-vous à cela écoutez
malheureusement je crois qu'on qu'on se
dirige à nouveau mais bon c'est la
réalité du Parlement européen qui a été
élu aussi hein
mais c'est la logique démocratique là
oui mais il y a bon il y a il y a eu des
élections effectivement le groupe le
plus important du Parlement européen
c'est le groupe de Monsieur Junker le
groupe de la droite il n'a pas de
majorité ce groupe à lui seul dans le
Parlement européen donc il y a il y a
une discussion et ce qu'il ne faudrait
pas c'est qu'on assiste à une sorte à
nouveau de grande coalition à l'échelle
européenne qui se fasse sur le dos
justement de l'exigence de réorientation
de la construction européenne donc c'est
pour ça que je dis j'attends de voir des
choses concrètes par exemple il y a sur
la table une proposition qui est portée
par la Confédération européenne des
syndicats un plan d'investissement
européen pour l'emploi à hauteur de 2 %
du PIB européen est-ce que François
Hollande soutient clairement cette
proposition et est décidé à la mettre en
œuvre en France et dans le reste de
l'Europe voilà des questions concrètes
est-ce qu'on va remettre en cause la
dirtive des travailleurs détachés qui a
été à peine toiletté et qui continue de
permettre le dumping social en Europe
voilà des questions concrètes sur
lequell moi j'attends des actes pas
seulement des belles paroles très bien
alors en France les le débat a commencé
à l'Assemblée nationale sur le budget
rectificatif et les frondeurs ce qu'on
appelle les frondeurs du PS vont
l'intention de présenter une quinzaine
d'amendements quel va être votre
position à l'égard de ces amendements
mais ces amendements nous nous les
examinons un par an à chaque fois qu'il
vont dans le sens de la réorientation
vers la justice fiscale nous sommes
prêts à les
soutenir il y a vous vous savez que
notre nous sommes totalement opposés à
la à la logique du plan d'austérité qui
est proposé avec d'un côté 40 milliards
d'allègements fiscaux pour les
entreprises pas de contrepartie et on
fait payer ça par 40 à 50 milliards de
coupes budgétair qui vont déprimer
encore l'activité donc nous nous sommes
opposés à cette logique maintenant à
chaque fois qu'il sera possible
d'arracher une partie de ces milliards
qui vont uniquement nourrir la
croissance financière pour les remettre
du côté du social nous soutiendrons par
exemple si il est proposé de mettre fin
à la mesure qui est envisagé par le
gouvernement de gel des prestations
sociales de gel des allocation logement
c'est-à-dire des amputations très
importantes du pouvoir d'achat des
ménages et bien s'il est possible de
remettre en cause ces mesures nous
soutiendrons ces amendementes on plus
vous vous opposer les arguments de la
Cour des comptes hein sur mais non mais
éc
les 2000 milliards de dett et cetera
mais le problème c'est que pour traiter
ces problèmesl est-ce que la politique
d'ustérité nous sort de la difficulté ou
est-ce qu'elle aggrave la difficulté ce
qu'on constate en Europe partout c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça qu'on est obligé de
parler de réorientation de la
construction européenne c'est que
partout on a fait des politiques
d'austérité on les a fait en même temps
résultat et bien on a déprimé l'activité
dans toute la zone européenne parce que
je rappelle que l'essentiel des échanges
économiques nous les avons entre pays
européens
donc quand on fait l'austérité partout
bah tout le monde s'enfonce en même
temps et on a un chômage qui explose
c'est pourtant assez simple à comprendre
et c'est pour ça que beaucoup de de voix
s'élèvent dans le monde économique dans
le monde syndical dans le monde
politique singulièrement à gauche pour
dire arrêtons avec ces politiques qui
sont en train d'assassiner la la
développement de l'activité et l'emploi
en Europe pensez-vous parvenir à mettre
le gouvernement en minorité lors des
débats sur le budget rectificatif
écoutez je je pz-v que le gouvernement
euh aura recours au 493 bah j'espère
qu'il n'aura pas recours au 493 parce
que ce serait quand même un comble de
voir un gouvernement qui se prétend de
gauche utiliser le 493 contre une
majorité de gauche il peut aussi
utiliser des procédures comme le vote
bloqué je rappelle malheureusement qu'il
l'a fait l'année dernière ici même au
Sénat dans le débat sur sur
l'an donc il peut il peut avoir recours
à cette tentation moi si j'ai un conseil
à lui donner c'est respecter le débat
parlementaire on voit bien que
maintenant la contestation des
orientations d'austérité actuelle elle a
gagné toutes les familles de la majorité
les écologistes les socialistes et
nous-mêmes les communistes et le Front
de Gauche donc il y a des des des
exigences qui s'expriment pas toutes
exactement les mêmes pas toutes
convergentes mais qui viennent de toutes
les familles de la majorité c'est donc
il y a il y a bien un problème avec les
choix actu Val il vous a entendu manuel
Vals non il n pour le moment il nous
entend pas il maintient il m il
maintient le cap les gestes fiscaux il
les a multiplié notamment pour les
ménages les plus modestes non il a il a
fait un geste fiscal après en avoir fait
d'autres après ce que après que les
gouvernements le gouvernement précédent
on a fait d'autres dans le sens inverse
parce que ça n'efface pas l'augmentation
de la TVA qui touche les plus modestes
et qui a été mise en œuvre au 1er
janvier de cette année et d'autres
mesures fiscales donc quand on fait la
balance on est très loin du compte et on
est encore dans un systèmeun très grande
injustice fiscal on vient de voir
récemment que les chiffres de rendement
de l'ISF allaient être supérieur à ce
qu'on avait prévu ça veut bien dire
qu'il y a des gens qui continuent de se
mettre quand même beaucoup d'argent dans
les ça veut dire qu'il y a beaucoup
d'exilés fiscaux qui rentrent ça c'est
l'action de Bery oui mais ça veut dire
qu'il y a beaucoup d'exilet fiscaux et
d'ailleurs les rapports officiels le
montrent c'est que les systèmes qu'on a
créé entre la fraude fiscale déclarer et
l'optimisation fiscale comme on dit
c'est-à-dire une bonne manière quand on
a beaucoup d'avocat cas qui se
fiscaliste autour de soi une bonne
manière d'utiliser les lois qui fait
qu'au bout du compte alors qu'on a
beaucoup de revenus beaucoup de fortune
beaucoup de capitaux on paye très peu
d'impôts et bien nous sommes dans cette
situation où il y a cette situation
d'inégalité fiscale quand Jean-Marc Kud
avait dit je je veux remettre à plat le
système fiscal moi j'avais dit chich
travaillons à cela bah pour le moment on
en est très loin vous le regrettez je
dire l'ancien Premier ministre non mais
j'ai j'ai pas à regrettercien Premier
ministre je ne l'ai pas nommé moi-même
et je pas moi qui ai décidé de le
changer et j'ai toujours dit que c'était
pas une question d'homme c'était une
question comment se présente cette
convergence rouge rose vert à laquelle
vous aspirez bah je je vois que
concrètement sur des des des sujets
précis elle est en train de elle est en
train de de voir le jour moi j'ai
participé à l'invitation de de
différents courants socialistes des à
des débats publics ces ces dernières
semaines j'ai répondu positivement à
l'invitation des écologistes à discuter
de nouveaux ob des nouveaux objectifs
d'une politique alternative aux
politiques d'austérité actuelle on voit
que le dialogue est en train de se Nuer
et pour moi c'est la priorité des
priorités maintenant parce que le
premier ministre dit la gauche va mourir
moi je dis si on veut pas qu'elle meure
et bien il faut se mettre au travail
mais sur une politique qui ne soit pas
la politique gouvernementale parce que
c'est ça le problème que pensez-vous de
Manuel
Vals c'est quelqu'un de très volontaire
mais je suis en désaccord assez profond
avec l'orientation politique qui est la
sienne euh lui depuis longtemps
d'ailleurs c'est pas une chose nouvelle
manuel Vals a été dans le Parti
socialiste celui qui a proné une voix
similaire à celle qu'on a connu avec
avec Tony Blair en Grande-Bretagne avec
schreoder en Allemagne et il le
revendiquait au effort il a même proposé
à une époque que le parti socialist le
Pr qui ont fait leur
preu écoutez non qui n'ont pas fait leur
preuv au plan économique qui ont qui ont
qui ont développé une très grande Pr
prité dans ces pays on oublie de dire en
Allemagne qu'il y a une très grande
précarité de l'emploi qui se développe
et on a une
situation qui à mon avis n'est pas
souhaitable pour le reste de l'Europe
c'est-à-dire un pays qui domine autour
de lui qui se sert des pays limitropes
comme des bases arrières pour faire
travailler des gens à bas coup au profit
de l'industrie allemande c'est vraiment
pas le modèle dont je rêve pour la
France non t les cas vous avez cité le
Premier ministre qui se demande si la
gauche peut mourir et ben on va voir euh
on va se poser la question dans ce cas
là que deviendrait le Parti communiste
regardez avant d'accueillir Perin Arnaud
et on dit merci à Pierre glachan ce
reportage de Samir dechir à
bobini bastion communiste pendant près
d'un siècle bobini fait partie des
défaites les plus symboliques du parti
au derniers municipal Catherine PGE qui
avait fait alliance avec les socialistes
a cédé son fauteuil à un maire centriste
beaucoup nous ont fait payer aussi une
union que nous pensions
vraiment utile et à laquelle les
balbiniens auraient été attachés ou au
niveau national les Français auraient
été attachés ils nous ont fait payer le
fait que nous étions aussi des soutiens
pour eux de François Hollande une
frontière entre les socialistes et le
Parti communiste devenue trop flou pour
les habitants je pense qu'il n'est pas
vraiment qu'il n'est pas assez dans dans
une opposition franche et qu'il est
plutôt dans une abstention tiède mais à
la section locale du Parti pas question
de céder à l'abattement élu et militants
s'interrogent sur les causes de la
défaite souvent attribué à la perte d'un
maillage territorial très fort quand
j'étais élue ou quand j'étais militante
de ma de mon quartier et cetera nous
avions beaucoup de proximité avec les
gens il y a 10 ans on avait encore des
secrétaires de cellules on avait des
trésoriers de cellules et ça on n' pas
on n' pas décidé de plus l'avoir on a
surtout c'est la vie qui a fait que ben
ça s'est arrêté on a eu des camarades
qui ont vieilli qui ont on eu marre
aussi et c'est vrai que pour nous c'est
une vraie difficulté maintenant c'est on
se retrouve dans les quartiers avec bah
très peu de gens qui ont envie on a des
militants mais on a très peu de gens qui
ont envie de prendre leur bâton de
pèlerin d'aller sonner toquer au portes
de son voisin vendre l'UMA Renault 23
ans s'est engagé dès le lycée au moment
de la bataille contre le CPE pour lui le
parti doit aussi moderniser son image je
pense qu'aujourd'hui au parti communiste
on a besoin on a besoin de réfléchir et
de de prendre le temps de se poser de
réfléchir de se mettre à jour sur sur
comment on communique comment on
s'exprime comment on utilise comment
Internet les réseaux sociaux qu'est-ce
que ça représente dans la société et
comment nous en terme de parti politique
ça peut être des outils aussi
extraordinaires de diffusion de nos
idées car ces idées pour l'instant ne
font plus le poids dans les urnes face
au discours de l'extrême
droite voilà donc pour ces questions que
l'on se pose dans une section communiste
comme l'on dit n'est-ce pas ce reportage
de samia dechir est très c'est des
bonnes questions sont des bonnes
questions vous les partager perine terna
est avec nous bonsoir perine bonsoir
Michel bonsoir Pierre Laurent bonsoir
qu'est-ce qui vous fait croire Pierre
Laurent qu' a encore une demande de
gauche en France bah je je le vois moi
tous les jours sur sur le terrain moi
quand je vais à la rencontre des
citoyens et que je leur demande comment
ils imaginent la société de demain ils
ils aspirent à une société d'égalité de
justice de de de progrès social de de
fraternité parfois ils doutent que ce
soit possible parce que la
mondialisation avec ces logiques de
concurrence semble s'être imposée de
manière très forte et donc il y a un
doute effectivement sur la possibilité
de l'obtenir mais ça ne veut pas dire et
c'est ce doute qu'on retrouve dans les
ures puisque les résultats de la gauche
sont quand même pas à la hauteur de
cette espérance oui mais on le mais on
le retrouve pour des raisons précises
aussi c'est que des gouvernement et
singulièrement celui-là qui se sont
réclamés de la gauche qui sont venus au
pouvoir avec des engagements les ont les
ont jeté aux Ortis à peine arrivé aux
affaires et effectiv mais vous
bénéficiez pas dans les ye d'une
alternative à gauche non parce que pas
encore je dirais parce que nous avons
commencé nous avons commencé ce ce
travail euh mais euh effectivement ça
demande ça demande beaucoup de euh
beaucoup de conviction beaucoup de
patience de persévérance ça demande
aussi on a vu des questions dans votre
reportage de repenser aussi nos
pratiques politiques euh pour être pour
être non compris mais écoutez vous savez
vous avez parlé de bobini en en en
île-de-fance pour ne prendre cet exemple
euh euh il y avait 48 euh villes qui
étaient dirigé par des communistes avant
les élections municipales il y en a 40
aujourd'hui euh après les élections
municipales
donc on en a perdu h on a gagné si on en
a gagné de pardon donc on en a perdu si
au total il y en avait bon donc voilà
c'est une situation moi je ne mésestime
pas ces difficultés mais il y a quand
même encore dans beaucoup d'endroits des
gens qui apprécient qui apprécie les
efforts que nous déployons vous dites
que le gouvernement a jeté ses idées aux
or en ses engagements vous dites que ce
gouvernement ne peut plus prétendre de
gauche mais je dis que la politique
qu'il mène n'est pas la politique pas
une politique de gauche n'est pas
politique de gauche attendue
effectivement par les Français mais ça
les urnes le montrent les gens c'est
c'est les gens de gauche qui se
détournent des urnes et qui
s'abstiennent d'ailleurs dans leur
majorité parce qu'ils ne trouvent pas de
réponse non plus ailleurs ils
s'abstiennent parce que ils souhaitent
effectivement le retour à des valeurs de
gauche Jean-Claude ma le leader de Force
Ouvrière qui était à votre place la
semaine dernière sur ce plateau nous a
dit que François Holland menait
exactement la même politique économique
que Nicolas Sarkozi est-ce que vous êtes
d'accord avec lui c'est vrai que les
fondamentaux de la politique n'ont pas
changé c'estàdire il y a deux dogmes qui
nous sont répétés en boucle il y a deux
problèmes soi-disant le coût du travail
et la compétitivité mais conçu comme
étant gagner contre les
salaires contre les salariés et nous et
nous et nous nous pensons que c'est une
erreur économique effectivement on fait
comme si il y avait une seule pensée
économique et qu'elle s'imposait à tout
le monde non on a le choix d'une autre
politique économique qui Paris sur plus
de justice sociale plus d'investissement
dans la qualité de l'emploi donc dans
les salaires plus de de formation et qui
cesse de privilégier les les les niveaux
de rentabilité des entreprises donc vous
regrettez d'avoir voté François Hollande
au 2e tour de l'élection présidentielle
en 2012 par non parce que je je pense
que la politique de Nicolas Sarkozi
aurait continué à
s'aggraver et que elle aurait été
probablement comme l'avait montré comme
l'avait montré l'entre de Tours
présidentielle elle se serait encore
radicalisé comme elle avait commencé à
le faire donc je n'avais rien à gagner à
maintenir Nicolas SAR au pouvoir et j'ai
fait un choix effectivement avec mes
camarades d'essayer de porter une
alternative de gauche François Hollande
la déçoit ça jette beaucoup de gens dans
le désarroi et nous nous avons à
reconstruire une alternative de gauche
mais c'est ce que nous sommes en train
de fairei vous tout le dialogue en train
deouer mais quelle forme quelle
concrétisation exactement ça ça va
prendre cette alliance il faut que nous
travaillons ensemble d'abord il y a des
mobilisations sociales il faut que nous
soyons au trava
ais
a avec socialistes nous devons
travailler un nouveau programme de
gouvernement un nouveau program deche
concrètement mais ça commence par
exemple n nous nous avons répondu
positivement Europe Écologie les vers
qui s'est adressé à toute une série de
formations politiques pour leur dire on
veut travailler sur trois sujets la
démocratie la transition écologique la
question de
l'emploi et bien demain nous allons nous
allons nous allons rencontrer les ver
avec le Front de Gauche nous allons
commencer ce travail je sais que les
vers veulent veulent mener ce dialogue
avec d'autres formations de de la gauche
et bien nous nous allons nous mettre au
travail avec eux et nous allons le faire
avec des socialistes j'ai dit tout à
l'heure j'ai participé à plusieurs
rencontres avec eux il y a la volonté de
poursuivre ce dialogue dans pour quel
projet parce qu'il y a quand même des
divergences de fond importantes entre
vous et les veres par exemple je pense
au nucléaire hein la la transition
énergétique et le dossier important aux
yeux des écologistes aujourd'hui en
France oui mais il il nous en parlons
nous en parlons très
très sereinement avec Emmanuel COS ça
n'empêche pas notre notre dialogue parce
que nous avons nous avons une ambition
de transition de transition écologique
qui qui je crois est convergente et nous
avons un débat sur la manière de
conduire cette transition écologique
nous sommes d'accord par exemple sur la
montée en charge très forte des énergies
renouvelables nous sommes d'accord sur
le fait qu'il faudrait développer le
transport ferrovière
pourc surotax aussi sur
l'cotax je pense que sur l'objectif qui
consiste qui consiste à réorienter parce
que c'est ça qu' y a derrière ce débat
géncité envir à à à réorienter une
partie du trafic routier notamment du
trafic routier marchandis vers des
formes de transport plus doux plus
écologique oui nous sommes d'accord sur
les moyens d'y parvenir et notamment sur
la fiscalité effectivement nous avons
des débats nous ne sommes pas toujours
d'accord donc ça c'est un dialogue avec
une partie des des verrs mais je lisais
ce weekend que Jean-Vincent Placé lui il
appelle au dialogue avec le centre il
déplore qu'à gauche et je site on cède
au repli et à la division alors que le
paysage politique est dévasté qu'est-ce
que vous dites aujourd'hui à jean-vc
tout ça ça fait partie ça fait partie de
la la discussion effectivement j'ai vu
que l'invitation de d'Emmanuel COS était
adressée y compris au au au modem je
j'ai j'ai dit à Emmanuel k que je ne
comprenais pas pourquoi donc mais ça
elle choisit de faire ce type
d'invitation non mais vous savez ce qui
importe c'est qu'on on ait la volonté de
travailler dans la même direction et je
crois que sincèrement il y a maintenant
un ensemble de force àait donc du MoDem
jusquau Parti communiste avec le Modem
non parce que le modem est est une
formation c'est pour ça que je ne
comprends pas cette invitation qui dit
qu'il faut graver dans le marbreil faut
qu'il faut graver dans le marbre le les
la politique de lutte contre les
déficits tel qu'elle est menée
aujourd'hui je vois pas pourquoi on
mènerait cette discussion alors qu'on
dit qu'il faut justement s'en écarter
parce qu'elle est en TR mener ces
négociations donc elle commence pour
construire une nouvelle force de gauche
hein si je je comprend bien mais en fait
un projet un projet sur des forces
divers avec ses passerelles entre ces
différentes forces mais en fait on
faisant ça vous ne faites que participer
à l'éclatement de la gauche et qui en
profite aujourd'hui vous le savez bien
c'est c'est l'extrême droite c'est
Marine Le Pen ce qui a divisé la gauche
aujourd'hui c'est le fait que c'est la
politique gouvernementale actuelle c'est
que cette politique gouvernementale au
lieu de de respecter des fondamentaux de
gauche oui c'est de la faute de François
Hollande François Hollande a fait un
choix politique ain de l'élection
présidentielle et a fait un choix de
politique économique qui a conduit à la
division de la gauche et au désastre
politique qu'on vient de vous sentez
aucun de tenu par aucun devoir de
responsabilité et même de loyauté
vis-à-vis même de cette gauche que vous
condamnez sachant que votre action ne
fait que favoriser l'extrême droite un
devoir de responsabilité non seulement
je m'en sens comptable mais c'est ce qui
me préoccupe tous les jours c'est que
moi je ne veux pas créer une situation
et je n'accepterai pas une situation qui
va conduire effec
la laiss la droite et l'extrme droite
sexpliquer entre eux au deè tour de
l'élection présidentielle mais si on
croit que pour résourre ce problème il
faut faire un appel à la discipline
derrière manuel Vals et bien moi je dis
c'est une grave erreur parce que c'est
précisément cette politique cette
orientation politique qui empêche la
gauche de rassembler donc la gauche ne
pourra pas se rassembler sur la
politique gouvernementale actuelle et
puisque François Hollande et manuel Vals
ne veulent pas l'entendre et bien il
faut travailler un rassemblement avec
tous ceux qui pensent que c'est
autrement et sur d'autres objectifs que
nous pouvons nous rassembler et je pense
que ce travail est en train de s'engager
donc si on vous écoute bien en 2017 si
François Hollande est candidat s'il
arrive au deème tour de la
présidentielle vous ne le soutiendrez
pas alors au
deè d'abord on est très très loin 2017
donc on va commencer par travailler
sérieusement sur les objectifs et
lui-même et lui-même dit si j'ai pas
fait reculer le chômage sa même pas si
je serai serai candidat à la présidence
donc on est pas là on pas mais quand
même aujourd'hui Pierre Laurent vous
êtes en négociation avec le Parti
socialiste pour les sénatoriales pour
éventuellement faire des listes communes
dans certains départements est-ce que
c'est un contradictoire avec votre
discours écoutez moi en aucun cas pas
plus dans les élections sénatoriales que
dans l'élection présidentielle je pense
que laisser la droite prendre le pouvoir
va résoudre les problèmes de la France
surtout quand j'coute j'écoute les
dirigeants de droite et quand je vois la
situation de l'UMP et quand je vois des
passerelles se créer entre le Front
national et certains secteurs de la
droite donc le fait que DE TOUTE faç
façon je travaille à essayer de
maintenir des positions majoritaires à
gauche est logique mais ça ne m'empêche
pas de dire que pour y parvenir il faut
mener un débat de ligne politique un
débat de cap un débat de de de choix
donc j'essayie de manier les deux choses
en même temps et je ne me sens
absolument pas contradctoire en ESS de
fa s'agit d'envisager il s'agit d'éviter
pardon que le scénat rebascule à droite
en septemre r absolument moi j'ai deux
objectifs pour les élections
sénatoriales essayer que le Sénat
bascule pas à droite et maintenir dans
euh la majorité au Sénat un groupe
communiste de du niveau qui est celui
qu'il a aujourd'hui donc une vingtaine
de sénateurs sénatrices et tout le monde
reconnaît que ce groupe joue un rôle
extrêmement utile tout le monde le
reconnaît dans l'hémicycle et tout le
monde le reconnaît à l'extérieur du
Sénat singulièrement les acteurs sociaux
qui savent trouver dans notre activité
un point d'appui solide donc je pense
que tout le monde a intérêt à ça Pierre
Laurent on a parlé tout à l'heure de de
Marine Le Pen qui n'arrive donc pas à
faire un groupe au Parlement européen
comment vous voyez cette chose ça
devrait faire réfléchir tous ceux qui
ont cru que en utilisant le bulletin de
vote de Marine Le Pen ils allaient
pouvoir se faire entendre ils ont Marine
Le Pen sera inutile au Parlement
européen elle fera partie des
non-incrits elle va vociférer mais sans
aucune proposition en revanche il y a
dans le Parlement européen un groupe qui
est le groupe de la Gauche Unitaire
européenne qui compte maintenant 52
députés et alors qu'il en comptait 35
qui s'est vu renforcer de manière très
importante avec les progrès de CISA ang
Griss euh des euh donc votre VO va
beaucoup plus
porter gche unitaire européenne va être
un groupe qui va beaucoup compter c'est
sur celui-là que le monde du travail va
pouvoir s'appuyer pour obtenir des
législations sociales plus profitables
une dernière question sur la réforme
territoriale qui arrive au Sénat la
semaine prochaine vous êtes opposé à à
ce projet du gouvernement pour vous il
faut laisser le millefeuille en l'état
moi je conteste l'idée du millefeuille
euh et et si on veut pas si on veut et
et en même temps je suis pour des
réformes mais sûrement pas avec la
méthode actuelle et une fois de plus
qu'est-ce qu'on est en train de nous
faire au lieu de revenir devant les
Français avec une réforme cohérente on
veut nous faire adopter un petit bout de
projet au mois de juillet avec
uniquement la carte des régions et le
changement de date des élections puis
après on nous fera parler à l'automne
des compétences et puis après je ne sais
pas quoi donc l'incohérence continue en
vérité pourquoi parce que le
gouvernement ne veut pas afficher les
objectifs vrai de cette réforme qui va
déliter le tissu démocratique et qui est
fait pour piloter l'austérité donc nous
nous voulons une vraie réforme démocrati
vous allez déposer beaucoup
d'amendements ici au Sénat on va déposer
des amendements on va continuer à réclam
à réclamer surtout un référendum on ne
peut pas changer à ce point les
institutions de la République sans
consulter les Français on est dans un
sujet dans ordre constitutionnel il faut
donc aller devant les Français et les
faire se prononcer sur la réforme
territoriale on a peu parlé de jeanluc
mélchonir
luiand on vous
VO veut dire le Front de Gauche c'est
inscrit dans le paysage politique lui
lui surtout il est jugé Meille
représentant de la gauche vous êtes
heureux de cela mais moi vous savez
c'est le témoin
que le travail qui a été mené depuis 4
ans par le Front de Gauche est inscrit
dans le paysage poou mélchant quand même
après son 6,6 % la du Scor européen est
le plus accommodant avec vous écoutez je
pense que au Front de Gauche en ce
moment on a on a entamé des discussions
tout le monde réfléchit il y a des
choses qui ne qu' faut changer dans le
Front de gauche il y a des choses qu'il
faut changer et et d'un mot il faut il
faut dialoguer avec des forces
disponibles hors du front GAE il faut
être plus ouvert plus rassembleur plus
fédérateur comme
VI Méch et et il faut être plus
collectif et il faut être plus collectif
parce que ça va se reconstruire autour
d'un projet
collectif ça va le coup de CIT Jean
mélchon merciine merci Monsieur Laurent
très vite à
bientôt